charge journal j'ai peur du vide qui
prend trop de place dans ma poitrine et
du brouillard dans ma tête je vois pas
au loin et si j'avance je risque de me
perdre alors j'observe le temps qui
passe la vie qui défile et le monde qui
paraît-il ne tourne pas autour de moi
mais bon ça reste encore à prouver
j'aimerais qu'ils s'arrêtent juste en
instants pour aller voir ce qu'il s'y
passe
rattraper le temps perdu à n'avoir rien
pu faire d'autre que d'attendre le bon
moment pour l'instant je suis à la
traîne mais quand on est si loin
derrière on peut penser qu'on est le
premier penser à rien de prendre tout
mon temps faudrait peut-être que
j'écrive mes idées noires si on a peur
de la page blanche se ferait toujours
quelques lignes et de plus en fait
il suffirait que j'arrête de me croire
pour que je commence à me faire
confiance je voudrais bien laisser la
porte ouverte mais si je ne laisse
personne entrer alors personne ne peut
m'abandonner et en même temps quitte à
n'avoir plus rien à dire un personne
pourtant ne rien dire à quelqu'un c'est
marrant quand même de se dire que aller
de l'avant et ne pas rester sur ce
qu'ils étaient avant
pardon la page est blanche et le sera
tant que je ne bougerai pas alors je
vais m'y mettre
et puis m'en remettre j'ai juste besoin
d'être un tout petit peu mélodramatique
avant de passer à autre chose
passer à quoi s'agit pas encore mais je
peux pas attendre éternellement le
dernier moment c'est pas maintenant je
pas pourquoi je suis shot depuis tout à
l'heure je suis tout seul c'est
complètement idiot